If rules exist, we’ll find a way around
them… and even Pokemon Go is no exception.
Players everywhere have found ways to bend—or
break—the game's rules.
Some of these methods are fairly harmless,
while others can get you banned.
Here's how to cheat in Pokemon Go—but don't
say we didn't warn you...
Egg-hatching machines
Are you too tired or lazy to walk around and
hatch those eggs you've had forever?
No problem—just use something else to do
it for you!
Creative Pokemon Go players have come up with
all sorts of ways to hatch their eggs without
also working their glutes.
Some trainers have even started strapping
their phones to their actual, real-life pets
before sending them outside to play.
Others use spinning household objects like
turntables, bicycle wheels, and even ceiling
fans to do the work.
Of course, don't use the spinning plate in
your microwave for this method.
Despite the memes floating around showing
a phone safely spinning inside a microwave,
if you do this, all you'll end up with is
a broken warranty, some dead Pikachus, and
a very disappointed dad.
Stealing gyms
After a Gym attack brings its prestige down
to zero, it becomes neutral until a player
places a new Pokemon in as a defender.
That may take a few moments, because players
can only use fully-healed Pokemon as defenders.
If you don't have creatures that are strong
enough to take over a Gym yet, those few seconds
are your opportunity.
Watch for the Gym to turn neutral, then immediately
tap on it and place one of your Pokemon in
there as a defender.
Next, go to your Shop menu and tap the shield
icon to claim your daily defender bonus of
Pokecoins and Stardust.
You'll claim a Gym without having to attack
even once.
Who needs friends when you have imaginary
dust?
Pick your Eevee-lution
When you evolve an Eevee in Pokemon Go, it
can turn into one of three different forms,
seemingly at random.
If you want some control, however, name them
after the original Eevee trainers from the
Pokemon cartoon.
Naming your Eevee "Sparky" will net you a
Jolteon; "Rainer" will get you a Vaporeon;
and "Pyro" will result in a Flareon.
You may need to restart your app after naming
your Eevee before proceeding with the evolution
process.
And remember: you can always change those
dorky names to something way cooler later.
GPS spoofing
Put simply, GPS spoofing is making your device
pretend to be at a location that you are not.
Some trainers, like popular YouTuber PewDiePie,
have gone to some extreme lengths to do this,
like strapping their phone to a remote-controlled
drone and flying it around while playing the
game via their laptop at home.
Technologically savvy cheaters can also install
a program called Bluestacks on their computer,
which creates a virtual Android environment
on the PC that acts just like a phone.
After rooting the device, they can install
a modified version of Pokemon Go, as well
as a GPS faking app.
Once everything is set up, cheaters can set
their "location" via the fake GPS app on the
device, open up Pokemon Go, and then play
the game without leaving home.
If you want to know more, you’re probably
a bad person.
Early reports indicate that most cheaters
who are being found out are only being given
a soft ban, locking them out of the game for
an hour or two at the most.
But there are also more and more reports of
permanent bans.
So, play fair, or get kicked out of Pokemon
for all eternity.
“Why don’t those stupid idiots let me
in their crappy club for jerks?”
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think of Pokemon Go cheaters…